I would love to ask you some rapid fire questions.
Are you guys ready?
(audience applauding)
Okay.
Here we go.
Dylan, song you can't stop listening to right now?
Uh, "Funny Girl" by Father John Misty.
Oh my God, I love Father John Misty so much.
Great.
Okay, Mason, what was the last lie you told?
That I enjoyed the dinner that my friend made me.
Oh, geez.
(audience gasping)
(Drew laughing)
Jasmine, where would you go
if you could go anywhere in the world?
I know you love to travel.
I'd love to go to Egypt.
I would love to go to Egypt.
(Drew gasps)
Great answer.
Okay, Mikey, what go-to binge food right now?
Popcorn.
Okay, Sonia, I need a makeup trend you're obsessed with.
Oh, the makeup I'm wearing right now.
It's like, a cut crease situation.
Yes, I see a cut crease.
Oh, you're so hot, I love it.
Okay, Dylan, you're going to order ice cream,
what flavor are you picking?
Something with cookie dough.
(everyone laughs)
I say just grab that cookie dough
and just eat it right out of the tube.
Mason, first date, drinks or art class?
Oh, the art class.
I wanna see if we're good at art
or compatible in that way.
That's cute, right?
Very nice.
Okay, Jasmine, you're stranded on an island.
What's the one thing you're taking?
Boom box, I need water.
I mean, I need music.
(audience laughing)
I was in my head, going water or a boombox.
So, boombox made of water.
Yup.
Okay, Mikey, do you believe in love at first sight?
Yes or no?
Yes, of course.
Okay.
And Sonia, if you have to pick one show
to recommend people to watch right now,
what would it be?
"YellowJackets" cause Jasmine is in it.
I agree, it's the best show ever!
Love you.
And as a last question to each one of you.
It's the same one
and it's the one I ended with Nev, Courtney and David.
So if you'll do me the honor of bringing it full circle.
I'm gonna start with you, Dylan.
What is the scariest thing about you?
Whoa.
(Drew laughs)
I feel embarrassed about how I look in shorts.
(audience laughing)
Mason, what's the scariest thing about you?
I'm incredibly competitive when it comes to dumb things
like, board games.
(Drew laughs)
Okay, Jasmine, what's the scariest thing about you?
I think the scariest thing about me
is who I become when I'm hungry.
I will snap on a dime.
I'll be so happy, cheerful, sweet
and then they're like,
"Oh no, we brought you the wrong order."
And I immediately start crying.
(audience laughing)
You get hangry.
Mikey, what's the scariest thing about you?
Well, I'm a very messy person.
A few people on the cast know this about me.
You're messy too?
Yeah. I'm trying to improve that.
Yeah. It's it's really bad.
Before my hair and makeup people came,
I had a bunch of dishes in the sink
and so I just like, put a towel over it.
Like, just gonna ignore that like it's not there.
So, maybe it's my, I don't know, my messiness.
Okay. Sonia, what's the scariest thing about you?
Oh, I sleep talk a lot and I sleep sing.
Like, I sing in my sleep.
And twice a year, I feel like,
yeah, once or twice a year,
I also sleep walk and do all sorts of weird things.
And you'll just find me in the kitchen,
in the middle of the night doing, I don't know what.
So I feel like it's terrifying
if you have a sleep over with me and that happens.
Yeah.
Okay.
I was wondering, in honor of "Scream"
and I had to like scream to get the film of ET,
so I sort of have this love for screams.
Cause it kinda changed my life, a scream.
I wouldn't be who I was if I didn't get ET.
And they really had an audition for me
where I had to scream.
So, I was wondering if all of us could take our phones,
starting with Dylan and go down the line.
And each of you could record yourself doing a scream.
My girlfriend is asleep, so I might scare-
By the way, you could do a scream that is like,
the I can't scream.
There's no rules.
It's whatever scream you interpret.
All right, watch this.
(audience laughing)
(muffled scream)
(audience applauding)
Perfect.
Okay, Mason, give it to me.
(loud scream)
(cast members laughing)
(drew laughs)
I love the quaff afterwards.
Jasmine, let her rip.
(loud scream)
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
Brilliant.
Mikey my love, go for it.
(loud scream)
(audience applauding)
And last but not least, Sonia.
(high-pitched scream)
(audience applauding)
Oh!
That was a high-pitched one.
All right, I'm gonna join you guys in solidarity.
Here we go.
3, 2, 1.
(loud scream)
(audience applauding)
That was good.
Thank you, Dylan, Mason, Jasmine, Mikey and Sonia.
"Scream" is out in theaters, January 14th.
We'll all be there for it!
(upbeat music)